on the road it's all about connection
it's all about being there for my fans
and bringing to life the art that I've
already created and I always meditate
before every show I say a prayer with my
crew and my band to kind of get to get
in the mode and I also stretch because
it's a very athletic show we got to
entertain
one of my original songs went viral
online and I thought there was no way
that this video had been be you know a
million times in 24 hours it was almost
kind of an emotional moment because I
had been working so hard for so long
with nothing to show for it basically
and finally it was like this is gonna
work and I think this is gonna be my
life and it was emotional it was
spiritual and it was exciting and
terrifying
my first real concert was back in 2012
and it was at Webster Hall in New York
City and it was this little basement
room I think it there was like 300
people and I didn't know if anyone would
show up you know I was like yeah people
would click on a youtube link but will
they actually leave the house and buy a
ticket to come see me and the show sold
out you know in like a week or so it was
just amazing to be like oh my gosh
there's an audience for what I do and
they actually care enough to come see me
back before I was touring I played at a
kid's fifth birthday party and like
there was about ten five year olds but I
was just playing in their living room
and I was like what has my life come to
and shortly thereafter was when I was
you know had my aha moment and realized
that I could really do music the way I
wanted to do
I love live performing I absolutely love
it and to be able to stand on a stage is
so different you know when you're in
you're in a studio and you're making a
video it's you know you can't see the
faces of the people that you hope will
watch it but when you are on a stage in
that moment you get to look out and you
see just these ecstatic faces of people
that have been looking forward to this
you never know maybe it's a moment that
they will remember for the rest of their
lives as you perform because there's
moments that I've had like that where I
was on a show and I'll never forget
those moments and they kind of helped
shape me to the person that I am the
numbers that I get to see on the screen
of my youtube videos those numbers
become real they become personal
suddenly and it makes it about
connection
you